ah ah bah t'es là c'est kurt salut bon
on a cru qu'il viendrait pas ouais j'ai
failli rester chez moi parce que j'avais
vraiment pareil viendront fait
injustement c'est pour toi allez c'est
moi qui commence je tue des gens avec un
arc
ouais bah c'est moi non pas du tout à
toi non au bout du rouleau pas du tout
non et non bon allez à moi je cours dans
la forêt mais je transpire risque pas
ouais bah c'est moi mais non c'est
toujours pas ça bon à moi parce que je
suis un homme
ouais ok j'ai une famille ouais est-ce
que je me sacrifie pour eux jusqu'à
faire des trucs illégaux non
jardon cacher ouais tu gères en patins à
roulettes candeloro non pas du tout ok
la toiture oui toujours pas non non non
non passer à quelqu'un d'autre
est-ce que je suis un homme
techniquement oui mais humainement tu es
vraiment une merde
ok mais c'est mon fils nantes est grosse
mais un thé un genre de tas de merde
d'accord je veux un dictateur oui voilà
tu es un dictateur et on voudrait tout
ce que tu crèves la gueule ouverte
tu comprends ça nazis non mais tu vaux
pas mieux tech une pourriture
bon alors maintenant à moi je fais des
cascades avec des vêtements ultra sexy
qui font de moi une espèce de sex-symbol
oui à batz et moi alors c'est sûr lara
croft et moi c'est pas toi on te dit que
ma maman d'avoir mis mon propre non
franchement c'est à droite ça fait trois
fois que je dis que c'est pas toi avoue
professeur yan eu de troisième mecs dans
leur qu'istres sur le pont supérieur
dans titanic c'est lui qui joue de la
trompette avec les belles moustaches
[Musique]
hockey
garnica nom peut faire un pendu
[Musique]